sir I'm glad listen how can you not be a
Rodney fan hey Noah you only had great
Rodney story oh 100 I do so maybe Rodney
Dangerfield I'm like 16 17 years old and
he um I suppose I'm getting ready to go
up on stage and Rodney comes and he
bumps me and he gets hey you can't go up
Rodney's going on so Rodney goes on and
he kills and I'm like I'm gonna go up
after Rodney and so no one to want to go
up so I went up after him and I do my
stuff uh and afterward Rodney is like
Hey kid what are you going to go with
all that stuff well that's cursing you
know and using it the language he like
gave me basically told me I wasn't
so I was like oh that was Crest falling
down when mine was blown and I was like
Rodney didn't like me he thought I was
too dirty and long story short maybe two
three years later I blew up and I'd
become you know Eddie hot shot and I was
at the uh uh in the bathroom to see this
Palace gone at the urinal and
Dangerfield comes and stands is right
next to me I look over and he looks and
says hey who knew
[Laughter]
but now we can do the interview what
were you saying oh you're gonna say
first of all that's that's awesome but
the thing I love about he said the same
jokes again and again over the course of
10 years I ate up every single one of
them could say the same thing it's the
character it's the character and the
delivery you'll laugh every time you see
it like if you watch archibanka if you
watch the Sanford and Son and they made
you laugh every time you watch that
episode it'll make you laugh it's the
character uh first of all sir I just
want to say again every time I've been
lucky enough to speak with you I am a
huge fan and I really want to say a
sincere thank you for all of your work
over the years and for making the entire
planet laugh and God bless you thank you
bro I I sincerely thank you um so I I
spoke to John Davis and John Fox not too
long ago and they told me they were
working on a documentary with you
um they've been doing that documentary
for
I did they they started that when I went
back to host Saturday Night Live so
what's that three years ago four years
it's been a while and I'm curious what
was it about what is it about this doc
that um that you said I'm gonna allow
myself to be filmed and I want to you
know tell my story
well I have been doing it so long you
know and there wasn't anything like that
and I've had a unique career so I was
like you know everybody does
documentaries now it's like well it's
it's been I've been doing it long enough
and there's enough stuff that there's an
interesting story there like how it all
how it all happened you know
my last thing on it is there like an end
point that you see where you're going to
stop filming or is it still being and
the end was uh because we had probably
ended maybe three or four months ago and
was like Hey I'm gonna get this uh uh
the Cecil B Demille award that's a good
way to end it so the end the end will be
that that winning that of getting that
award I am very much looking forward to
seeing this uh jumping into why I get to
talk to you uh you've said to me in the
past that you enjoy sitting on your
couch being with your kids and are
selected with what you want to do so
what was it about this project that said
I'm gonna get off the couch and I'm
gonna go make this well I had been on
the couch for like 10 years and it was
like okay um I want to do something and
my my batteries had recharged and and I
forgot about why I went to the couch in
the first place what happened in the
first place was that it got to where I
was was just wasn't having fun making
movies it was like okay I don't want to
be on pages making movies I've been
having fun making and he's just doing it
because they offers you a lot of money
because you could see that you can see
that when you go see those movies you'll
see it be like what the is this
movie it's like oh the artist supposed
to just got a big check for it and I
didn't want to do any more movies like
that so uh once my batteries got
recharged and I wanted to work again I
got off the couch and then I want to do
different interesting things I'm a huge
fan of Jonah's work I'm a huge fan of
your work and you both make me laugh so
much uh there's some great stuff between
the two of you especially when you're
driving together and I'm just curious
what was it like collaborating with
someone like Jonah who was also he's
very good on his feet very good with
that was so much fun to work with
because most actors don't can't do that
you can't most actors uh
they do they step this on the script and
if you go off script or you start
playing around like I've been in scenes
with you know actors just be looking at
you
you'd be going to go all over the place
and then just kind of looking at you if
they cut off so yeah I was watching it
they started watching you but Jonah if
you go off script he's right there with
you and sometimes he'll go and you got
to come with him and uh he's funny and
smart it was fun working with him I I
really enjoyed what Kenya did with the
editing in between the scenes and it
just felt like he just did a really
great job with the material um can you
sort of talk about what he was like
because this was his directing his first
feature what was it like actually
collaborating with him and finding
different things in the moment it was
easy I had one we had not one Awkward
Moment uh he's super smart and super
talented and
being a showrunner he's been the
showrunner on blackish but he's done
that so you kind of you know it's being
a showrun is as close as you can get to
the director's experience you know where
you're in charge of everything and every
decision and all that so he's been there
he's worked with actors and worked with
technical people and and had to do that
dance so
it was cool we never it was real easy
going sneaker culture plays a part of
this film uh and I don't believe you get
to wear any I don't remember seeing you
wear any cool sneakers was that
something that you wanted for your
character or did you take any from set
because there's a lot of cool stuff in
this movie well sneaker culture is
character wouldn't be a part of the
sneaker culture My Generation uh the
sneaker culture hadn't jumped off yet
that happened you know when I was grown
when I was a kid there was no it was
really no sneaker coach you had a pair
of uh Chuck Taylor Converse or some
Pumas or
that was that was it some Pumas or some
Chuck Taylor's my last thing for you if
they weren't Pumas with Chuck Taylor's
they called them skips you had on some
skips
my last thing for you I am uh so looking
forward to the new Beverly Hills Cop
um because you're in it and I know that
it has to be good if you're coming back
to this role
um what was it that finally said I'm
gonna make another one what what what
finally got you to do it uh Jerry
Bruckheimer the original producer when
he got involved and he started
developing the script and he knew what
Beverly Hills Cop is supposed to be uh
when he got back involved that's what
that's when it all started to come
together as we tried for years and years
maybe 10 12 years to to then I must have
read five or six different scripts and
it was never right in the studio was
like let's go here it is it was like no
it's just
Jerry Bruckheimer got back in there and
known and he knows his and he put
it together he did Top Gun just last
year and the Bad Boys is Jerry bruck
kindness so we have that same brain
behind Beverly Hills Cop and he put it
he put all the pieces in place that were
required for us to make a great movie
and I'm excited for people to see it
it's really hard to make though
because because axle Foley is 21 and I'm
not 21. I'm not 21.
that's a long time ago and it's a really
physical movie and you know I had to do
some physical stuff and I know Tom
Cruise likes to do physical stuff but uh
you started off the interview but I like
to be on the couch I don't like to be
jumping over and shooting and running
and I had to do some jumping and
shooting and running and as a result you
know I had a knee brace at the end of
the movie had a knee brace and my back
is messed up and all that but but the
movie is going to be you know
special on that note I need to stop
again I want to thank you so much for
your time and for all of your work have
a fantastic day too man have a good one
now